[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, everyone.
My name is Andrew Wales.
I'm a Developer Programs
Engineer on the Google
Analytics Developer
Relations Team.
And I'm here to talk today in
this episode of "Off the
Charts" all about exception
tracking and why you guys
should be doing it.
And in particular, I'm going to
show you five reasons why I
think you should be measuring
exceptions today.
So just to take a step back and
maybe get some context on
the problem as a whole.
So all apps, obviously, crash
at some point, right?
There's no perfectly
stable app.
So all of our apps are going
to have useful crash data
that's going somewhere.
And what I'm going to try to
show you is that crashes are
going to provide an opportunity
for us to improve
our app experience
for end users.
And by measuring these crashes,
we can make better
products, we can make more
money, obviously, so it's a
win-win for developers
and users.
So before we get started talking
about the five reasons
I think you should be doing
exception measurement, I just
wanted to cover some exception
measurement basics.
So what is exception
measurement?
Maybe you've heard that
term before, but
you've never done it.
Basically, what I'm talking
about is measuring fatal
crashes and non-fatal
exceptions in
native mobile apps.
And in particular, in Google
Analytics, this is really
about seeing crashes and
exceptions in context with the
rest of your app usage
and e-commerce or
in-app payments data.
There's a lot of solutions out
there to do different kinds of
crash measurement.
And if you're an Android
developer, for example, you
may already be getting
crash and [? ANR ?]
data in the Google Play
Developer Console.
So what really sets analytics
apart is that you're going to
be able to see the crash data in
context with all the other
app usage data as well as
your e-commerce data.
And this is actually
really powerful.
And I'll show you in a little
bit what you can do when both
of those things are combined.
But one of the examples is you
can see the effect of a crash,
for example, on e-commerce
payments or in-app payments.
So there's some prerequisites
for getting started with doing
crash and exception measurement
that I just wanted
to go over.
Luckily, there's really
only two.
Number one is that you should
download the GA SDK for
Android or iOS.
And you can do that at our
developer site, which is at
developers.googl
e.com/analytics.
And then, number two is just
follow the Getting Started
Guide if you haven't already.
That's going to get the SDK
implemented in your app.
It's going to get some
of the basic
measurement features in place.
And actually, if you complete
that Getting Started Guide,
you'll already have implemented
automatic crash
measurement, which I'm going to
talk about in a little bit.
So you'll have a leg up, and
you'll already know how easy
it is to implement this stuff.
So one more bit of context
before we jump into it.
Exceptions in Google Analytics,
they're comprised
of two collection fields.
So this is the stuff that you're
actually sending to GA.
So the first field
is a description
field, and it's a string.
And it's, as you might guess, a
description of the exception.
There's a 100 character
limit on this field.
So you can't take an entire
stack trace, dump it in, and
send it to GA.
And I'll talk about later,
actually, why you won't want
to do that for some
other reasons.
It's really meant to be a pretty
short description of
the exception that occurred.
The second field that you send
when you measure an exception
is this isFatal field.
And this is a Boolean and just
indicates whether or not the
exception was fatal, ie,
was it a crash or
whether it was a non-fatal.
And so we're just going to
call it an exception.
As far as your reporting options
go, so once you've got
your data, we have
a brand new--
well, it was new a little while
ago, new if you haven't
used our app reporting.
But it's a crashes and
exceptions report.
And this is really going to be
the go to for most people to
get data on their crashes and
exceptions and see how that's
trending by release version,
et cetera.
And that's in the engagement
section on the left-hand nav.
And then, additionally, we have
the exception description
dimension and the crashes and
exceptions metrics, which you
can use pretty much however you
want in custom reports, in
dashboards, and as
custom segments.
So if you want to go beyond
what's in the crash as an
exception report, and I'll show
you some examples of that
today, you can definitely do
that using these dimensions
and metrics.
Just one note for those people
are using the Core Reporting
API, these dimensions and
metrics are not yet available,
but they will be coming soon.
So with that said, let's jump
into the meat of this.
So five reasons you should be
measuring exceptions today
using Google Mobile
App Analytics.
So the first reason I'm going
to talk about is automated
crash reporting.
Basically, you should be
measuring this data because it
is dead simple to
send it to GA.
Number two, you want to know
how stability is trending
across your releases.
So are new releases introducing
more bugs than
they're resolving
or vice versa?
This is a really nice thing to
be able to know so that your
team can check on it as you put
out additional releases.
Three, so you can find out
what crashes are actually
costing you.
And costs aren't always in app
revenue or in-app payments,
although very often they are.
But that could also be things
like user engagement metrics.
You might see those suffer,
and you might consider
that to be a cost.
So it's interesting to know
the relative cost of each
exception to figure out what
impact it's having on your
user experience.
This can also help you
prioritize fixing certain
issues as well.
Number four is going
to be see which
devices are least stable.
So especially in the Android
world, there's a ton of
devices out there that your
app may be running on, and
it's really difficult to be able
to test on all of them
before you release.
So being able to see by device
easily where the crashes are
occurring can give you an idea
for, if some device is
crashing a ton or your app's
crashing a ton on a device, it
might be something you want to
look into testing before you
do your next release.
So that can be really
helpful as well.
And number five, you can get
insight into trends of caught
exceptions as well.
So this is--
I'm going to be going back and
forth between caught and
uncaught exceptions.
Uncaught exceptions are what
I would call crashes where
there's no handling
code, so the app,
basically, just crashes.
But you are going to have a lot
of caught exceptions in
your app as well.
And some of these may be really
valuable to track and
measure as well.
And you can do that
using the SDKs.
So let's jump right into
the very first reason--
automated crash reporting.
So, basically, it is-- and I may
be exaggerating a little
bit-- but it's dead simple to
get this implemented whether
or not you're using EasyTracker
for Android, or
you're using an advanced
implementation on Android, or
if you're using iOS.
So let me show you
how easy this is.
So with EasyTracker, all you
need to do is add just this
one line to your XML file--
that's usually analytics.xml,
but it could be anywhere--
that just basically says turn on
report uncaught exceptions.
And that's all you need to do.
It's just one line.
It goes with the other
configuration settings then
you have in your analytics
XML file or
wherever you store them.
And that's pretty much it.
If you did nothing else and
just released your app, at
least you would get data back
that shows you crashes, a
description of the crash, and
you'd be able to do most of
the things that I'm going to
mention today where you can
segment it by device, and by
app version, et cetera.
So super easy.
One line and you're done
for EasyTracker.
But even without EasyTracker,
if you have an advanced
implementation, it's actually
still pretty simple.
In the SDK, we provide a class
called ExceptionReporter.
And you, basically, would just
create a new instance of
ExceptionReporter,
and you hand it a
couple different arguments.
One of which I wanted to point
out here was that you actually
give it the current default
uncaught ExceptionHandler.
And then you set that
ExceptionReporter to be your
new default uncaught
ExceptionHandler.
So what's going to happen is
that when there's an uncaught
exception, our exception
reporter, the GA
ExceptionReporter, is now
going to pick that up.
We're going to track an
exception, we're going to
dispatch it, and then we're
going to hand it over to
whatever the default exception
tracker was before.
So if you haven't done anything
crazy or custom,
that's basically going to mean
that the crash data is going
to get sent to Google Play, if
need be, and then the app's
going to exit just as normal.
So that's pretty much it.
Even without EasyTracker, it's
still pretty simple.
And most of the examples
I'm going to give
today are for Android.
But I did want to show a quick
example for iOS just to show
you that just like with
EasyTracker, it's actually
just one line of code to get
automatic crash tracking up
and running.
So you can see here
you just add this
line to your app delegate.
And it's very similar to the
XML file in Android or very
similar to that.
You just turn it on to send
uncaught exceptions.
So in terms of what's actually
sent out by this automatic
exception reporting, GA is going
to send the exception
type, the method name, the class
name, and the thread
name, where we can,
automatically.
We don't--
well, I'll get to that
in a second.
Additionally, all these
automatically reported crashes
are going to be considered
fatal.
Because these are all crashes
that were picked up by an
uncaught ExceptionHandler, so we
consider that to be fatal.
And this is the point
I wanted to get to.
We don't really recommend
sending the stack trace reason
or trying to stuff a whole bunch
of information from the
stack trace into the
description field.
Number one, because the
description field is actually
quite small.
It's only 100 characters.
But number two, and maybe more
importantly, that stack trace
may contain some sensitive
personal information or
personally identifiable
information.
And it is a big no-no to send
that kind of data to GA.
So our solution sends exception
type, method name,
class name, and thread name.
And if you're doing this on your
own, I would recommend
that you send similar fields.
So that's automatic exception
tracking.
So no matter how you've
implemented our SDKs, it's
either going to be one line
of code or maybe two
lines of code tops.
And you don't have to worry
about it from then on.
It's going to collect data on
all of these crashes and send
it back to your GA account where
you can then segment it
by all these great dimensions
that we'll
talk about in a bit.
So in sum, you should do it
because it is very easy, and
everybody should be
getting this data.
But let's talk a little bit
about what you can do with the
data once you have it.
So the second reason is that you
want to know how stability
is trending across
your releases.
So I mentioned it earlier, but
basically, the idea here is
that you want to know if a new
release is actually producing
a whole bunch more crashes, if
it's less stable than a prior
release, or vice versa.
If you had a bunch of crashes
in one release, and you put
out a bunch of fixes in your
next, you want to see that
number come down.
And it's very useful
to be able to track
progress against that.
So what we want to see in GA is
crashes and exceptions by
app version.
And this is something that
we make it really easy.
Actually, the default view of
the crashes and exceptions
report is going to show you
a breakdown of crashes and
exceptions as metrics and then
app version as the dimension.
So we can see in this example
here, there's an app.
This version 1.1.7 has a ton
of crashes and exceptions.
And our app version 2 has far
fewer-- only 91 compared to
about 7,000.
So it could be that version 2
just came out, so maybe you've
got to give it more time.
But it looks like we're making
some pretty good progress here
in terms of making a more
stable experience in
this version 2.
Now, you can take this
a little bit further.
You can take the same report and
segment it by platform or
OS version as the secondary
dimension.
And this gives you even more
granular insight into where
crashes are coming from in
each of your releases.
So in this example, you can see
here we've still got app
version on the left side as
the primary dimension, and
it's showing 1.1.7.
But then we've added this
operating system and version
second dimension.
And so now we can see, OK,
within my app version 1.1.7,
within that release, show me the
breakdown of crashes and
exceptions across these
different versions of Android
in this case.
And so here, we see that,
actually, most of the crashes
and exceptions were
coming from some
version of Android 4.
There's some for Android
2 Gingerbread, but
mostly it's in 4.
So it gives you an idea of hey,
maybe this is a place we
can focus on.
Maybe there's something specific
that's going on here
that we can take a look
at and try to fix.
You can use other dimensions
there as well.
Operating system and version was
just the one I thought was
most interesting.
But if you had, for example,
Android and iOS, and you might
want to just break down app
version by platform, you can
just do that as well.
And one last thing you can do
with this that I think is
pretty cool.
You can take the app version
dimension and use it in a
custom segment so that you can
compare crashes over time
between two or more releases.
So in this example, what
I've done here,
I've created two segments.
They both use the app version
field name, and then the
values of those fields are going
to be the releases that
I'm interested in.
So I have a segment for version
1.1.4 and version 1.1.7.
I've applied them both to the
crash as an exceptions report.
And then I can see over time
in this nice graph what the
trends are for each version.
So for example, in this case, I
may have pushed some kind of
bug fix sometime in the
middle of January.
And you can see both versions
actually come down.
So that's great.
But version 1.1.7 is actually
still showing a bunch of
crashes over time.
So it might be that I want to
look in there more closely.
Third reason, and I think this
one's really cool and
highlights one of the real
strengths of tracking
exceptions with GA, which is
that you can get a sense of
what crashes might be costing
you both in terms of
e-commerce revenue
or user metrics.
So let me show you how
you might do this.
I'll just jump right into it.
So the first thing you do to set
this up, you're going to
create a custom segment
using the
exception description field.
And then, the value of that
field is going to be whatever
exception you're interested in
seeing the cost of-- whatever
the cost is to you.
Then you are going to create a
second exception, and you can
call it something
like Baseline.
And that exception is going to
exclude all sessions that have
that crash description,
the one that you used
in the first segment.
So now you have one segment
that says, give me all
sessions in which this
particular crash occurred, and
then another segment that says,
show me all sessions in
which that crash didn't occur.
And that's your baseline.
Now, you can apply both these
segments at the same time to
pretty much almost any report
in GA, but it's particularly
interesting to see it applied
to a goals or an e-commerce
report to see how a crash might
be affecting outcomes.
That might be able to help you
determine how you should be
prioritizing fixing that bug
over maybe other bugs.
You can also use it to see a
difference the impact on user
engagement metrics.
So in this case, this example
down here, you can see that
I've got average time on
screen and screens per
session, two pretty common
engagement metrics.
And I've got my baseline
sessions there.
So 11 seconds is the average
time on screen.
But for those users
who run into this
ProfilePicker crash--
so it's some sort of crash when
you are trying to pick
your profile, some user data--
there, average time on screen
is actually much lower.
It's about three seconds.
And in terms of screens
per session, our
baseline is about five.
But in sessions where we hit
this crash, that drops
down to about 1.3.
So that's a pretty big deal.
So if a user is normally using
the app and getting into it
about five screens deep, and
then all of a sudden this
crash is causing those sessions
to be just one screen
only, that's a pretty serious
problem that you might want to
look into further
and prioritize
it to get it resolved.
I'm going to keep
rolling on here.
So number four.
This is particularly important,
I think, for
Android developers.
But this is seeing which devices
are the least stable.
So you can't always test on all
devices before you launch.
And I know there's a lot of
solutions out there that offer
testing solutions like that
where you can actually maybe
get close to testing
on all devices.
But for those of us who aren't
doing that, you have a couple
devices maybe that you're
working on in development.
You try to test as
many as you can.
But eventually, you have
to release it.
And in the Android world, that
means your app could get used
on any number of devices that
you may or may not have had
time to test.
So one of the useful things you
can do with this exception
data, now that you're collecting
it, is that you can
create a custom report to see
crashes and exceptions broken
down by device model.
So here's an example of
what that looks like.
So I've used the mobile device
marketing name as the
dimension here.
I just think it's a nice one
because it gives me back the
device names that I know, like
Galaxy S III, rather than a
model number or something
like that.
And then, you can see crashes
and exceptions per device.
So in this case, obviously,
there's a lot of crashes on
Galaxy S III.
That may be just because more
people are using the S III to
use your app.
But it may be something
you want to
take a look into further.
For example, on a Galaxy Note
II, that may be a device you
haven't tested at all.
You might want to drill in there
to see what kinds of
crashes are happening there.
Maybe it's a device you want to
target for future testing
before you launch the
next version.
And just quick, to create a
custom report, I use mobile
device marketing name as the
dimension, crashes and
exceptions as metrics,
and then you get this
pretty clean report.
So the last thing I wanted to
talk about was monitoring
trends in caught exceptions
as well.
So a lot of what I've
been talking about
is measuring crashes.
So these are uncaught
exceptions.
But there's a lot of cases
in your app where you're
expecting that exceptions might
be thrown, and you're
catching them and handling them
gracefully in a way that
the app does not just boot the
user back out to the home
screen as it would in a crash.
So there's a lot of value,
actually, in
measuring some of these.
So I wanted to talk about
this one as well.
So again, yeah, caught
exceptions probably won't
crash your app, but they're
still valuable to measure.
And I use the word selectively
here, because I'll show you in
a second what I think might
be one valuable use case.
There's a lot of cases where
you probably don't want to
measure caught exceptions, and
it's actually a waste to send
GA that much data and have to
use the radio on the device
that much to send us the data.
So let me show you an example,
just a small
code snippet here.
Suppose this is from a game.
And what's happening here is
that I've got a list of high
scores that are stored in the
cloud, that when a user
finishes a game in my app, I
want to be able to request
those high scores and show
them to the user.
Now, I'm expecting that this
might throw an exception,
because for some reason, the
high scores might not be
available, the server might now
be reachable, et cetera.
So I've set this up to
try and catch blocks.
And in my catch block, I've
added just two lines here.
You could actually shorten
it down to one.
But, basically, I just get a
reference to my tracker.
And in this example, I'm
using EasyTracker.
And then from that tracker, I'm
going to send an exception
that basically says, OK I tried
to get the high scores,
something went wrong, so
I'm going to send this
exception to GA.
And I've just included just a
simple message like "high
scores are unavailable." and a
false Boolean value indicating
that this wasn't fatal.
And then, you'd go on
from there with
whatever code you need.
So on the reporting side, what
that might look like is that
you get something like this.
And this is a similar example.
I pulled it from a real live
account, one of ours, where a
caught exception kept coming up
when the server was failing
to respond.
So, basically, users were asking
for data, they were
sitting there waiting
for it, and the data
was not being returned.
So we wanted to make sure we
caught that exception.
And this is what it would look
like in your reports.
Two tips on this.
If the request for data, if
it's a common one that
requires the user to wait for
a long time, this is also a
case where you might want to
track that latency using our
User Timings feature.
That's probably a whole
different GDL, but I just
wanted to mention it.
In cases like this where the
user is sitting there waiting
for data to come back from the
cloud, and they're actually
just sitting there.
It's not asynchronous, Their
experience is stuck
until they get it.
That's a good use case for
user timings as well.
Another tip, you should probably
only measure caught
exceptions when they're having a
big impact on user behavior.
So in this example, I've been
saying over and over, the user
is sitting there waiting for
something to happen, right?
That's an important thing to
measure, because it directly
impacts the user experience.
You want to know how
many times that
exception is being caught.
In other cases, you're probably
catching all kinds of
exceptions all over the
app for a bunch
of different reasons.
But if they're not directly
impacting the experience of
the user, I wouldn't recommend
tracking them.
You're going to end up sending
us a ton of data and using
much more of the radio to send
us that data, which is bad for
battery life anyways.
And when you get to the reports,
it's not entirely
clear what that kind of data
would be useful for.
So I would recommend just
stick to the big caught
exceptions that are really
going to affect the user
experience.
So just to recap the five things
that I just kind of
rushed through.
Number one is automated
crash reporting.
This is super easy to set up.
So everyone can get this
data in just one or
two lines of code.
Just grab the SDK, implement
it, and you're pretty much
good to go.
You don't have to do
anything else.
If you don't want to send any
other data, that's fine.
You can just send us crashes.
And it's really simple
to set that up.
So number two, the second
reason, knowing how stability
is trending across releases.
So we looked at ways in which
you can segment your
exceptions and crash data
by app version, app
platform, et cetera.
You can track progress against
total number of crashes and
thereby stability over
time as you keep
putting out new releases.
Three, find out what crashes
are costing you.
And again, I think this
one's really cool.
You can create segments for
particular crashes and compare
them to sessions in which that
crash didn't occur to get a
sense of what the impact is on
user engagement metrics, but
also on your e-commerce and
in-app payments as well.
Number four, seeing which
devices are least stable.
And this one, again, was really
important for Android
users who have to deal with a
wide variety of devices, and
they won't always be able
to test on all of them.
So this is pretty
cool as well.
And number five, because you can
get insight into trends of
caught exceptions.
And these caught exceptions
can represent moments when
there's a big impact
on user behavior.
So it can be really useful
to grab this.
And the example I used was if
you're requesting data from
the cloud and the user is
sitting there waiting for
that, and there's an exception
that's thrown because the
server is not available, that's
something that's really
valuable to measure
and hopefully
minimize in future releases.
Cool, so that's it for me.
Five reasons you should be
tracking exceptions.
If you have questions,
feel free to hit
the Developer site.
It's developers.googl
e.com/analytics.
We've got developer guides for
iOS and Android to help you
get started with those
really quickly.
You can also catch me
on Google+, and my
name's Andrew Wales.
Thanks, guys, for coming to this
"Off the Charts" session,
and hopefully I'll see
you again soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]